Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với có hợp ít
sao miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao dành
cho người mới bắt đầu được thực hiện
trên kênh YouTube gà Excel bài số 23
word table trong Excel trước khi bắt đầu
vào bài học số 20 mình cùng giải bài tập
số 19 của hôm trước nhá các bạn mở bài
19 lên mình sẽ vào phần câu hỏi
Ừ ok Đây là cái vùng dữ liệu của mình
nhá câu hỏi là gì ạ khi mà các bạn bấm
các chương p các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây là có
bốn trang này Bây giờ làm sao để mình
hiện ở đây là một trang duy nhất nhá thì
để làm việc này các bạn là mới sau nhá
đầu tiên các bạn sẽ nhấn back để mình
quay lại này các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ view
này sau đó các bạn chọn đấy ạ page Break
preview đấy thì sau khi các bạn chọn
fabre preview thì bạn nhìn ở đây này Nó
sẽ có bốn cái vùng nhỏ này chết một Tức
là cái vùng rộng nhất này Đây là paspa
này các bạn có thể nhìn thấy cái chữ
tiếc nhưng mờ đây này hết 4 và hết hay
đấy và các bạn sẽ nhìn thấy các đường
sọc xanh đây này các cái đường rọc xanh
này sẽ ngăn các trang với nhau bây giờ
để ko về một trang thì cách rất là đơn
giản là việc các bạn sẽ di chuyển vào
cái phần sau xanh này khi mà nó hiện
tượng mũi tên và sẽ dang hai bên đấy thì
các bạn sẽ giữ chuột trái và các bạn kéo
sang đây đấy các bạn kéo sang phải nhá
sát với cả cái đường sang ngoài cùng thế
này để sau khi Và Nó
mọi người cầu nguyện các bạn sẽ bỏ các
chữa cháy ra đấy như vậy là gì nó là về
cái kết 1 này rồi nhá Bây giờ các bạn có
thể undo các bạn ấn cái chữ z nhé đấy
hoặc là gì Các bạn có thể kéo cái đường
này các bạn kéo xuống dưới cho nó sát
tất cả đường biên giới này là được đấy
và diện kẻ đường bên này các bạn lại kéo
tiếp sang phải đấy thì như vậy là toàn
bộ Cái này đã được thành một trang rồi
nhá Bây giờ có bạn sẽ và các chế độ lo
mà các bạn bấm tăng trưởng phê này
ở đây gọi đấy chứ Đây là một của một lấy
chọn thêm rất là hai ạ Ok như vậy là
mình đã xong cái câu hỏi của bài số 19
nhá các bạn sẽ đó nghe câu hỏi này lại
mình sẽ vào bài 22 phút table trong
Excel để các bạn xem ở cái bài 20 lên
các bạn chú ý mình sẽ để cái link tải
file thực hành trong phần mô tả cái dưới
video tốt nhất là các bạn tải về các bạn
vừa theo dõi và thực hành cùng mình nhá
Nếu như bạn nào không biết cách tải về
thì các bạn có thể theo dõi các bài đầu
tiên trong ngày đấy mình đã hướng dẫn
các bạn khá là chi tiết cách để các bạn
tải về nhá Thì Okay Đây là cái file dữ
liệu của mình nhá các bạn có thể kéo các
thanh trượt lên xuống này Đấy dữ liệu
của mình ở đây rất là lớn nó có khoảng
gần 5.000 hàng cơ đấy Facebook thấy bồ
là một công cụ mạnh rất là hữu ích trong
excel các bạn có thể phân tích số lượng
làm báo cáo vẽ biểu đồ
kết quả đơn giản chỉ việc kéo và thả đặc
biệt với cái dữ liệu của bạn lớn và yêu
cầu nó hay thay đổi thì file Portable là
vô cùng hữu dụng để sử dụng file host
thay đổi đầu tiên các bạn sẽ thích vào
một ô bất kỳ trong cái vùng dữ liệu này
sau đó các bạn sẽ vào thẻ resort đời Các
bạn sẽ chọn thế ạ Các bạn chọn cái file
table Hoặc là các bạn có thể chọn cái
comment Bypass Google nhá Đấy mình cứ
vào cái bút p.bồ đi thì chọn tích vài
phút thay đổi thì lập tức một cái cửa sổ
christie's bye Chúc thầy bồ đã được hiện
ra đúng ạ thì đầu tiên đấy Nó là cái
vùng dữ liệu đấy nó sẽ là điện từ cái dữ
liệu đầu tiên là ok 4 đến các dữ liệu
cuối cùng là cái Oh ép 4998 đấy Đây là
cuộc ép này và 4998 là cái hạn cuối cùng
nhá các bạn chú ý nhá ở đây cái vùng dữ
liệu nó là đô la tức là nó đã cố định
rồi Nếu như các bạn dùng cái cốc tay bổ
đây thì nó sẽ có nhiều điểm là gì khi mà
các bạn thêm dữ liệu mới tức là các bạn
xem thêm các khách hàng
Ừ nó lớn hơn 4998 nhá thì diện dữ liệu
đó sẽ không tự cập nhật được đúng ạ thì
như vậy Ở đây mình có một cái mẹo để
mình có thể tự động cập nhật số liệu khi
mà thêm các hành mới nhá đấy các bạn sẽ
bấm cancel đi đấy thì trước khi tạo cái
bút thay đổi thì tốt nhất là các bạn
phải tạo một cái bảng Thay bồ cho nó
đúng không ạ thì vẫn là trong cái thẻ y
dược này các bạn sẽ thích vào cái thay
đồ thì một cái cửa sổ clip tiếp thay vì
đã được hiện ra đúng không ạ Đấy thì nó
sẽ bàn là gì từ bị ô đầu tiên đến cái ô
ô cuối cùng các bạn Nhớ thích chọn là
ngoài thấy bố hết đời nhé sau đó có
thích ok đấy thì như vậy là chị cái vùng
dữ liệu của mình đã được tạo thành một
cái thấy bồ đấy ở bên phải đây này các
bạn có thể thay đổi cái kiểu hiển thị
của các thầy bùa này đây ví dụ Các bạn
chọn cái kiểu hiển thị nào thì tùy các
bạn nhá đây ví dụ mình chọn cái kiểu này
đi Bà Rịa Ở bên trái đây này các bạn có
thể đặt tên cho nó nhá Đây là cái tên
mặc định của Excel nó sẽ tạo ra đúng
không ạ Các bạn có thể để cái tên này
hoặc các bạn có thể
Anh ở Nha Ví dụ mình đặt tên là diện
mình có thể đặt tên là dữ liệu đúng ạ
Các bạn thứ nhất tên phải là liền nhau
đây sau đó các bạn ấn enter thì như vậy
cái thêm hồi dữ liệu đã được tạo ra đúng
ạ Bây giờ có ăn xuống dưới này Ok Bây
giờ giả sử các bạn thêm một cái kiểu dữ
liệu mới nhá lại ví dụ vẫn là gì ạ tháng
3 này ngày 21 năm bao nhiêu 20 20 đấy
các bạn ấy Mũi Tên Xanh đây để mới nhập
tiếp đấy cậu thấy chưa ngay khi mà các
bạn thêm một dữ liệu mới thì cái dữ liệu
này nó đã được thêm vào cái Thay bồ đấy
đây ví dụ Các bạn ăn cơm trước đi là
miền Nam ví dụ đây là các bạn có thể ấn
can.bi nhé để mình copy ví dụ đây là
điện sản phẩm 01 đi chẳng hạn thế nhá
Đấy doanh thủ đây mình cho là diện 30
lại gọi enter thì bạn chưa nhá Khi mà
các bạn thêm một cái rượu mới này thì
cái dữ liệu này nó sẽ được tự động nó
vào cái Thay bồ này các bạn sẽ thấy cái
vùng chấm chấm Nhỏ đây à tức là đây là
cái điểm cuối của cây bồ đấy Giả sử bây
giờ mình Bôi đen nhá các bạn có thể để
dẫn đến cái Hàn cuối cùng
ở một chỗ nào Thế nhá các bạn có thể bấm
hai chân đi lại các thấy chưa thì như
vậy là bất cứ khi nào Dữ liệu các bạn
thêm vào thì nó sẽ tự động nó cập nhật
và cái cây bồ này Đấy bây giờ có thêm
vào thẻ Insert này các bạn chọn quay
Portable sẽ nhận thấy chưa thì cái vùng
mà lựa chọn thì chính là tên của cái
thai bồ mà mình tạo đây này Đấy cho nên
là dịp khi các bạn thêm dữ liệu vào thì
nó sẽ tự động cập nhật và cái thêm bộ
này chúng mình tiếp theo là người đó sẽ
có một cái tùy chọn là các bạn sẽ tạo
cái quay mốt anh bù ở cái xít mới hay là
trên VSIP mà mình đang ở đây cũng ạ thì
thông thường vì sáng tạo cái poster vụ ở
cái thích mới nhá hệ của bạn sẽ bấm ok
thì như vậy nó sẽ tạo ra một cái xít mới
ở đây để chứa cái bios thấy bồ này bên
phải là cái cửa sổ file word thấy bộ
phim để các bạn có thể tích rượu ít ở
đây để các bạn đóng lại ạ Còn nếu như để
hiện cái Facebook thay bộ phim chỉ các
bạn lại thích vào cái phi lý ở đây đấy
còn Thúy Nga kêu ít này nó sẽ nằm ở cái
thẻ aline này khi gọi
Ừ thì nó sẽ không hiện biến thể like và
khi các bạn tích vào cái vùng tay vuốt
thai bổ đây thì nó mới hiện cái thẻ arai
và thẻ visa thôi đấy các bạn sẽ thích
vào cái si líp nhá như vậy cái file word
table phiêu ở đây nó sẽ có các cái Thành
Phần đầu tiên là cái thành phần search
là mình sẽ nhập tìm kiếm này Đây là cái
vùng dữ liệu của mình đúng ạ dữ liệu của
mình gồm có các thông tin là ngày tháng
này khu vực nhà phân phối sản phẩm và
doanh thu đúng ạ Còn đây là bống cái Ô
Bây giờ mình sẽ kéo vào mình sẽ giải
thích cho các bạn nhá đầu tiên giả sử
mình kéo này ạ khu vực và filter này sản
phẩm như chất kéo dâu này nhà phân phối
mình sẽ kéo vào cái ô k lần này và cái
doanh thu mình sẽ kéo vào cái ra Lưu Đấy
Bây giờ mình sẽ giải thích cho các bạn
nhá cái vùng phiên tờ đây này chính là
cái vị trí phiên tờ ở đây đấy các bạn có
thể tích mới đây và các bạn chọn các cái
thành phần của cái khu vực ở đây nhá Ví
dụ mình tích vào se Lac Mat tinh ở đây
này mình bớt dại mũi miền Bắc thôi
Vì vậy các bạn sự tích Ok Đợi tí nhưng
phải cái vùng dữ liệu này là của miền
bắc không Thôi nhá Đấy còn có thể tích
mới đây mình có thể hiện mình có thể sẽ
đôi lại các bạn bằng Ok thì như vậy cái
vùng filter ở đây chính là cái dữ liệu
tin tưởng ở đây tương tự cái phần da ở
đây là cái sản phẩm đây nhá thì chính là
dạng Đây là toàn bộ cái cái sản phẩm từ
sản phẩm một đến sản phẩm 10 ở đây này
Đấy còn cái phần nhà phân phối ở đây
chính là cái hàng dữ liệu nhà phân phối
ở đây đấy còn cuối cùng với phần quan
trọng nhất là cái phần dữ liệu ở đây là
doanh thu đúng ạ thì mặc định với cái
kiểu dữ liệu là số thì mặc định nó là
kiểu xong tôi là tính tổng đúng không
Các bạn có thể tích vào đây Các bạn chọn
cái vali xưa shipping đây này Đấy thì
các bạn có thể thay đổi cái kiểu dữ liệu
nha nếu như mình không thích tính tổng
thì mình có thể thuận cao này chọn Eros
chọn mắc trận Nguyên đây có một số kiểu
dữ liệu thông dụng thì thông thường
người ta hay trận tổng nhá hoặc
ở Everest gạo sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy dữ
liệu ở đây là trung bình đúng ạ Bây giờ
mình sẽ đổi về cái tập này các bạn sẽ
thích vào đây các bạn sẽ chọn là Bari
free shipping các bạn thích là xong nhá
Bạn bấm ok thì như vậy Ở đây là gì đây
là cái thành phần tính tập bây giờ để bỏ
các thành phần ở đây ra thì các có thể
giữ chuột trái vào đây và các bạn di ra
ngoài đấy rất là đơn giản hoặc là diện
các bạn lên đây các bạn chỉ cần tích lại
rồi đây ví dụ các bạn tích vào nhà phân
phối còn bỏ ra nhắc bạn thích rồi đây
đấy thì nó cũng bỏ cái nhà phân phối ra
đúng ạ Cái sản phẩm các bạn có thể bỏ ra
đấy các bạn có thể kéo khu vực vào cái
phần rau này cũng được đấy các bạn có
thể kéo tiếp với nhà phân phối và Râu
cũng được đấy thì tùy cái mục đích của
các bạn nhá đấy các bạn có thể kéo sản
phẩm vào cái phận-khang làng được để gọn
thấy đấy con có thể kéo cái phần ngày
vào cái phần filter cũng được và trong
cái phần này có bạn có thể chọn báo cáo
của bất kỳ các ngày nào Bố bạn ví dụ Các
bạn thích vào đây mình sẽ bỏ silicone
Mình sẽ chọn cái ngày mùng 3
Ừ mùng 6 đi chẳng hạn thế bạn sẽ Bống Ok
thì như vậy dữ liệu ở đây là dữ liệu của
ba ngày thôi nhá đấy các bạn có thể bỏ
cái phần filter ra ngoài thì tùy vào cái
nhu cầu sử dụng của các bạn nhá lại ví
dụ các bạn giữ được trái bọn kéo hết ra
ngoài đi bây giờ mình sẽ để cái sản phẩm
đây chẳng hạn thế này cái nhà phân phối
mình sẽ để đấy Đấy cái khu vực nha các
bạn thích thì các bạn có thể để vào cái
phần filter cũng được Bây giờ cái phần
số liệu ở đây này các bạn thấy không Nó
chưa phân cách hàng nghìn Các bạn nhìn
thấy rất là xấu bây giờ con sẽ nháy
chuột phải vào một cái giá trị bất kì
nhắc bạn nhớ thì phải vào đây các bạn sẽ
chọn cái Lumpur này các bạn sẽ vào cái
gì à Cái nằm bờ các bạn sẽ tích vào đây
thế nào mình sẽ sử dụng cái dấu phẩy để
ngăn cách khách hàng nghìn với nhau các
bạn sẽ giảm nên Tức là mình sẽ không để
gây số thập phân sau số nguyên nhân các
bạn thân 4 OK lấy bạn thấy chứ hệ số của
mình đây rất là đẹp rồi ạ Ok Giả sử bây
giờ mình có thể mình kéo thêm với khu
vực và cái dâu này cũng được nhá
khi chọn kéo xuống đây thì là gì ạ Các
cái khu vực ở đây là rẽ các khu vực miền
Bắc thì sẽ có cách sản phẩm này khu vực
miền Nam là có các sản phẩm này để bạn
có thể tích và cái dấu trừ ở đây này Đấy
thì các bạn sẽ lìa các bạn sẽ thu gọn
lại thì họ sẽ biết rằng Miền Bắc bao
nhiêu miền Nam là bao nhiêu miền chung
là bao nhiêu trong trường hợp mà các bạn
muốn xem cái chi tiết của miền Nam hãy
thì gọi sẽ tích bằng dấu cộng này đấy
thì sản phẩm 01 của miền Nam là bao
nhiêu sản phẩm không hay là của miền Nam
là bao nhiêu người gặp đều rất là hay
tại các bạn có thể bỏ cái dấu cộng này
bằng cách thực hiện đây là nó có cái
cộng trừ đây là có thích một đây thì nó
sẽ không còn các cái dấu cộng đây nữa
lại còn sẽ tích vào đây thì nó lại hiện
lại cái dấu cộng ở đây để mình có thể
xem cái thành phần nhỏ hơn nhá Đấy các
những khá là hay ạ đây ví dụ mình bỏ cái
miền Bắc đi đây mình xem cái miền Bắc
cái sản phẩm này nhá Bây giờ các bạn có
thể vào cái thẻ design này Đấy một số
cái tùy chọn nha các bạn có thể diện Đây
là cái thằng xuất tôi tờ này các bạn sẽ
thích mình
thì các bạn có thể bỏ chọn study các bạn
sẽ liệu các bạn sẽ chọn là dulot sâu sắc
tờ đấy thì nó sẽ không hiện các cái sắp
tuột ở đây nữa đấy Bạn thấy ví dụ mình
chọn miền Nam xuống đây thì nó sẽ không
còn với pháp tu từ ở đây nữa đấy còn
trong trường hợp mà các bạn muốn hiện cả
cái sắp tu tờ Tức là mình muốn nhóm các
cái thông tin các sản phẩm của khu vực
miền Bắc đấy đấy thì chọn sự tích và các
phép tu từ và các bạn sẽ chọn là sâu hôn
sắp tờ này các bạn có thể sâu ở dưới của
group hoặc các bạn sẽ sâu ở trên đỉnh
của group Ví dụ mình tích vào đây là sâu
vào top group đây này đấy bạn thấy chứ
trong trường hợp các bạn không muốn sâu
sắc tờ thì bạn chọn ở trên này Đấy mình
sẽ ăn hết đi tiếp theo là cái Grant ơ
nhá mà các bạn không muốn hiện ở đây nhá
đây chỉ còn làm như sau nhé bạn xem vào
cái phần Grand Total đây này các bạn sẽ
chọn họ bây giờ mình sẽ học cả lâu và cả
cá lầm Đây là cái ca lần này lại còn đây
là diện Đây là cái dâu này Đấy Bây giờ
mình sẽ off đây nhá các bạn sẽ vào cái
Grand Total đây các bạn sẽ off cả lô cả
các lần đi đấy còn thấy mất cả
thế này đây cũng mất luôn để rất là hay
đấy các bạn lại vào thẻ Ninja Thì cái
phần V boxlayout thì thông thường mình
hay chọn là gì mình sẽ hay chọn cái sâu
in tabura for đây các bạn có thể chọn
các cái kiểu hiển thị khác nhá và gọn
xem nó khác biệt như thế nào đây khi mà
các bạn chọn cái sâu in Ciputra for này
thì lúc này là gì ạ Cái này nó sẽ có khu
vực sản phẩm đó đây là xong và doanh thu
đấy Cái này rất là hay đấy Ok mình có
thể bỏ cái phần khu vực ra ngoài nhé
chẳng hạn thế lại chiến nước này là gì
sản phẩm đây tiếp theo Bà Rịa các bạn có
thể sắp xếp cái phần Sản phẩm này nhá
tên đang là thứ tự tăng dần nhé Cậu có
thể tích vào đây các bạn sẽ giảm dần
cũng được đấy rất là thứ tự các sản phẩm
sẽ giảm dần tương tự các bạn có thể sắp
xếp theo cái phần doanh thu ở đây ví dụ
là sang thu theo nhà phân phối FPT nhắc
bạn có thể nhấn chuột phải vào đây các
bạn có thể xỏ để sau từ nhỏ đến lớn hoặc
tư lớn số nhỏ thì tùy các bạn nhé đợi
rất là hai ạ oke
Ừ với lại bỏ cái nhà phân phối ra nhá
mình sẽ test cái sản phẩm này cho các
bạn ạ Bây giờ các bạn có thể kéo thêm
các doanh thu vào cái ô value này cũng
được đấy thì nó sẽ hiện diện Xong rồi
Kênh thu thứ hai cho bạn có thể kéo
nhiều cái cũng được nhắc nó không ảnh
hưởng gì cả Ok cái này mình sẽ ko lên
một tí gái như vậy Ở đây là dễ cái doanh
thu mình chiếc kéo qua đây ba lần đúng ạ
Bây giờ các bạn sẽ vào cái doanh thu Thứ
hai này các bạn sẽ vào vali free
shipping ví dụ cái này mình sẽ để trung
bình đi Đấy Ok cái danh tôi thứ ba này
nhé các bạn có thể nhớ thì phải vào đây
này các bạn chọn địa sâu values Ví dụ
mình sẽ chọn là diện phần trăm ở trento
thì nghĩa là gì ạ nghĩa là cái sản phẩm
10 đến này nó sẽ chiếm bao nhiêu phần
trăm nó sẽ chiếm 5.24 phần trăm sản phẩm
cung chín sẽ là chiến sĩ thì nó sẽ chiếm
là 916 phần trăm đây là tổng tất cả Đây
nói trên da là một trăm phần trăm rồi
còn thì uống rất là hay luôn đấy như vậy
Ở đây mình có thể cạnh biểu diễn doanh
thu dưới dạng là diện tính cầm trung
bình và tỷ lệ phần trăm đấy Ở đây mình
sẽ vào cái thẻ view nhá mình sẽ
Ừ cái sâu Phong L3 cái sắc mặt doanh thu
nha các bạn có thể đổi tên nha các bạn
sẽ thích bảo với sau một doanh thu này
các bạn lên cái Thanh Phong L3 bạn đổi
lại Ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ ghi lại địa tổng
doanh thu đấy Cái đây là gì ạ doanh thu
trung bình đúng không anh thu trung bình
hạ thế Đây là diện đây là tỷ lệ tỷ lệ
phần trăm các bạn enter đấy thế như vậy
Cùng là một doanh thu thôi Nhưng mà mình
có thể biểu diễn dưới nhiều cách khác
nhau đúng ạ Cái này các bạn có thể nhấn
chuột phải nhá để chọn Nó phóng bạn nằm
ở đây mình sẽ chọn nó nằm bờ đấy ai cái
phần trăm này cái trung bình các bạn có
thể để hai cái số sau số thập phân đi họ
sẽ vẫn ok đấy các bạn thấy như vậy cùng
là doanh thu thôi nhưng mà dễ biểu diễn
được nhiều cái này đây rất là đẹp luôn
ok nhé mẹo để mình sẽ copy một cái vie3t
bồng anh là địa cậu sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ
cái vùng Facebook Thay bồ đây này để các
bạn sẽ nháy Việt
ở shopee tư là lúc này mình sẽ copy cái
file gốc Thay bồ luôn đấy ạ Các bạn sẽ
thích vào cái ô này chẳng hạn thế nhá
đấy các bạn sẽ càng chơi vô luôn tức là
mày chết luôn đấy Bạn thấy chưa thì như
vậy cái dữ liệu này là cái dữ liệu iPad
Thay bồ đã được tiết ra rồi đúng không
Mình rất kéo cái sản phẩm ra đấy các bạn
chú nhé cái Facebook thấy bộ phim này là
cái Facebook của cái vùng thấy bồ thứ
hai đây này chứ không phải là cái thai
bù ở bên trái nên đâu nhá Đấy bây giờ ví
dụ mình kéo khu vực với ra như vậy Cái
bên này là mình tính theo sản phẩm đúng
không còn bên này mình sẽ theo dõi theo
các khu vực đúng không Thì như vậy mình
sẽ biết được là khu vực nào là hiệu quả
nhất khu vực nào là hiệu quả thấp nhất
đúng không Ngoài ra thì các bạn có thể
tạo cái đồ thị cho nó nhanh ví dụ A
Kotex vào đây này các bạn sẽ vào thì các
bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ like Các bạn chọn
Viber trả đấy thì nó sẽ có rất là nhiều
cái kiểu đồ thị của bạn Nga đấy các bạn
có thể tích chọn cái đồ thị nào mà các
bạn mong muốn nhé ví dụ mình chọn cái
file này đi cả sẽ bấm ok đấy thì như vậy
chị sẽ có là diện tổng doanh thu này
doanh thu trung bình và tỷ lệ phần trăm
các bạn lấy là tổng doanh thu về doanh
thu trung bình hết tỷ lệ thì bản chất nó
đều là giống nhau Cái màu cam và đây là
miền Nam vào đây này là nhiều nhất chiếm
là 40 phần trăm này miền chung là bao
nhiêu là 35 phần trăm và miền Bắc là nhỏ
nhất đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ nhấn chuột phải
vào đây các bạn sẽ chọn vào 2 ô ô phiêu
bác từng Trả này đây lại mình sẽ để mỗi
cái phần khu vực này thôi nhé các bạn có
thể kéo cái thông tin vào đây lại Ví dụ
mình sẽ kéo rộng ra đấy các bạn có thể
vẽ đồ thị cho cái phần Sản phẩm này cũng
vậy nhá ví dụ có thể tích của đây các
bạn vào gì adalah Các bạn chọn file gốc
rằng Ví dụ mình vẽ cái hình cột đấy đi
lấy đoạn Sơn bấm ok thì như vậy đây là
gì ạ tổng doanh thu của các cái sản phẩm
nhé các bạn nhớ thì phải vào cái phần
vali này các bạn sẽ hay ôn đi Đấy bây
giờ ví dụ mình chỉ lấy cái tổng doanh
thu lên nhá các bạn sẽ thích mà cái tỷ
lệ này các bạn không biết đi để cái
trung bình cũng vậy các bạn Kích chuột
trái 1
anh đi Mình chỉ lấy cái doanh thu thôi
đúng ạ Cái tổng doanh thu gọn thích vào
đây mình chắc và cái đây Leesin đây này
cả thích đến đây mình sẽ để cho ở Bác
cầm đi đấy như vậy mình chẳng biết được
là tổng doanh thu của các sản phẩm này
là bao nhiêu đúng ạ rất là hay luôn Đây
là cái cách để mình vẽ đồ thị cho cái
phần Facebook nhá bây giờ còn nhớ là
phải còn đi lên đi cắt đi đấy để bỏ cái
đồ thị Các bạn nhớ thì phải dọn cắt đi
đấy tiếp theo mình sẽ giới thiệu cái
phần slicer các bạn nhé đây các bạn có
thể tích vào vùng Facebook thay đồ Ví dụ
mình vào đây là file gốc thay đổi thứ
hai đây này đây các bạn xem vào cái thẻ
Garena Các bạn chọn là in Slider cho
mình nhá Đấy thì mua cái cửa sổ Insert
slicer đã hiện ra đúng không các bạn sẽ
có thể chọn cho mình là diện các bạn có
thể chọn cho mình là nhà phân phối này
theo ngày ở đây chẳng hạn thế là họ rất
thích ok thì như vậy sẽ có hai cái
slicer một cái nào treo nhà phân phối
vào một cái là theo ngày ở đó các bạn sẽ
chọn cái Cleo như thế nào mình sẽ lựa
chọn toàn bộ các ngày nhé
ạ bây giờ cái nhà phân phối có thích vào
đây này các bạn sẽ vào cái option Ví dụ
nhà phân phối mình sẽ để ở chia làm 2
cột đi các bạn enter đấy Gọi sẽ kéo lên
đây cái ngày ở đây cũng vậy có thích mới
đây ví dụ mình chia thành diệu mình sẽ
chia thành 4 cộ đi lại bạn enter lại xài
cái này mình sẽ có thể mình kéo rộng ra
thì các chứng á Cái Slider đây là theo
ngày á thì nó sẽ là rất là nhiều ngày
đúng không Trong trường hợp mà bạn muốn
giám sát theo tháng theo năm thì tốt
nhất là cái tầng sĩ một đó đây các bạn
sẽ chèn thêm một cái cột tháng và 1 năm
thì lúc này các bạn sẽ có cái slicer của
tháng là năm cho các bạn nhé Đấy bây giờ
có còn chưa Nháy chuột phải các bạn sẽ
cắt cái slideshare đi thì mình sẽ làm ở
cái phần nhà phân phối thôi chẳng hạn
thế đấy Khi mà có bạn muốn kiểm tra các
nhà phân phối của FPT chọn sẽ tích của
FPT thôi đấy
à Vậy là cái dữ liệu ở bên này nó là của
FPT để họ sẽ tích và gái xe này ạ Đây là
cái doanh thu của bạn gái Excel VNPT
Viettel đúng ạ trong trường hợp mà các
bạn muốn lựa chọn nhiều bên nhà phân
phối để có ăn theo dõi thì các bạn sẽ
thích và đây là các bạn sẽ lựa chọn được
Monte tức là nhiều cái nhà phân phối
luôn các bạn thích vào đây Đấy thì nó có
cái hình chìm mm đây này Đấy Lúc này các
bạn có thể giám sát ví dụ Viettel và FPT
Shop và FPT nữa lại thì đây là cái doanh
thu của Viettel và FPT đây là của VNPT
lại các bạn thích lại một lần thì bạn sẽ
thành bỏ chọn và tĩnh lại một lần thì sẽ
là chọn đấy nhá lại các bạn có thể bỏ
chọn và chọn tùy vào cái nhà phân phối
mà các bạn muốn theo dõi thì các bạn thứ
nhất cái slicer này đang có tác dụng
trên mỗi cái cái cốc thấy buồn này thôi
bây giờ mình muốn cái sân này nó có tác
dụng cả cái phần theo dõi theo sản phẩm
ở đây nữa thì mình làm như thế nào đấy
thì cách rất là đơn giản thôi ạ Các bạn
xem nháy chuột phải vào cái sẽ lại xơ
này và các bạn chọn cái report colection
ở đâu đấy
cho em một cái cửa sổ report lesson đã
hiện ra đúng không Đây là cái thì cái
trạng thái của cái slideshare lại rất là
cái sân này nó đang có tác dụng trên cái
quay ba table2 thôi và nó chưa có tác
dụng trên cái tai có thể đột ngột Ở đây
bây giờ có rất tích vào đây thì là gì
Nghĩa là cái slide show này nó sẽ có tác
dụng cho cả cái vai mốt p.bồ một ở bên
này nước đúng không ạ sẽ bấm ok đấy Bạn
thấy chứ bây giờ quên sẽ tích vào đây
thì cả cái p.bồ một này nó sẽ thay đổi
theo giờ gặp thấy không rất là hay nếu
như mình bỏ chọn One Piece IX nhé Thì
mình sẽ chỉ chọn được một thôi Đấy mình
sẽ bỏ tích vào đây mình sẽ chọn được
nhiều cái nhà phân phối đấy còn thấy
chưa Rất là hai ạ Ok như vậy Mình nhắc
tóm tắt xong cái file word table trong
Excel nhá lại mình sẽ xem cái câu hỏi
của phần bài tập về nhà OK câu hỏi là dị
vẫn là cái phần dữ liệu giống như cái
phần kia nhé yêu cầu của mình ở đây là
gì đây các bạn sẽ vẽ cho mình hai cái
biểu đồ ở đây là gì
ý theo dõi theo cái phần sản phẩm và đây
là đấy thì mình đánh giá là gì đây là
các cái sản phẩm từ sản phẩm một biến
sản phẩm 10 đúng không còn màu đây là
theo các nhà phân phối đây lạnh màu xanh
này là phân phối FPT này màu đỏ này là
gã Excel màu xám này là Viettel và màu
vàng VNPT đấy gọi thấy đây là cái tỷ lệ
phần trăm rất là hay rồi Ví dụ mình sẽ
biết được làm ở đây cái biểu đồ Ví dụ
như cho biết là cái sản phẩm 01 này tỷ
lệ các nhà phân phối là bao nhiêu thì
các bạn nhìn với lại con sẽ thấy này cái
màu xám này của cái sản phẩm 01 này là
cái doanh thu lớn nhất là cái tức là
công Viettel của cái thằng 01 này là lớn
nhất và cái ông màu xanh và màu đỏ đây
là nhỏ nhất đúng không để tương tự các
sản phẩm khác cũng vậy nhá các bạn sẽ
biết được là cái sản phẩm nào của nhà
phân phối nào là có tỷ trọng lớn nhất và
nhỏ nhất nhá thì tương tự cái biểu đồ
thứ hai đây là gì mình sẽ theo khu vực
đấy màu xanh là miền Bắc màu đỏ là miền
Nam và màu xám là miền chụp đấy còn thấy
không Mẹ rất là hay mình sẽ biết được là
tỷ trọng theo khu vực
cả của các sản phẩm nhé Trên này là diện
tỷ trọng theo các nhà phân phối của sản
phẩm đấy bài tập về nhà cho các bạn là
như vậy nhá những chuyện đó lại Ok như
vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày hôm
nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các
bạn nhé Đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật video
mới nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ để giúp
mọi người cùng học Excel nhé Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại ở
ừ ừ